Get ready for a bit of a bummer, true believers.
Mighty Marvel might be running like a well-oiled
machine, but according to writer/director
James Gunn, it's going to take a little longer
than we might like for that machine to pump
out Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3.
In a recent exchange with a fan on Instagram,
Gunn revealed that the three-quel for the
spacefaring team of misfits won't start filming
for, quote, "another year or so."
The news isn't entirely unexpected, as we've
known for quite some time that Gunn will have
a bit of work to wrap up for the Distinguished
Competition before he can turn his attention
to Guardians 3.
As you may recall, the director was temporarily
fired from the Marvel flick due to a kerfuffle
over some nearly decade-old tweets in 2018;
he was reinstated in March 2019, but in the
meantime, he had taken a gig with Warner Bros.
and DC Films writing and directing the soft
reboot The Suicide Squad.
Marvel, in no hurry to rush Guardians 3 to
the screen with its slate already chock full,
allowed Gunn to finish up his work on the
DC film before returning.
According to CBR, Gunn has said that shooting
on The Suicide Squad is only about two-thirds
complete as recently as December 18; assuming
the flick sticks to its production schedule,
it's likely to wrap by February or so, at
which point Gunn will be knee-deep in the
post-production process for another several
months.
Of course, nobody would blame Gunn if he wanted
to cool his jets for just awhile before taking
on another massive comic book film, so his
stated time frame for Guardians 3 to begin
production sounds just about right.
However, assuming that shooting does indeed
get underway in late 2020, we can infer that
we've got a pretty damn long wait before the
flick actually hits theaters.
Consider that The Suicide Squad has been slotted
for release on August 6, 2021; this means
that from wrap to release, we're looking at
a period of about 16 months.
If Guardians 3 has a fairly typical 3-4 month
shoot, then it'll wrap right around March
or April of 2021 and if it has a comparable
post-production schedule, the very earliest
we could expect to see it hit screens is July
or August of 2022.
The sequel to Black Panther is already slated
for release on May 6 of that year, and Marvel
has a number of other films that might shoulder
their way into its two remaining 2022 slots,
including Blade and the third installment
in the Ant-Man series.
It follows, then, that Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol. 3 may not even appear in theaters until
sometime in 2023 — more than three years
from now.
Guess we'll all just have to pop into hibernation
for a bit, huh?
"Do one of those on me!"
"Sleeeep."
While the MCU's feature schedule is all sewn
up through Black Panther 2, there are still
a number of flicks in addition to those already
mentioned that don't yet have release dates.
Perhaps the most high-profile is Captain Marvel
2, the sequel to the 2019 billion-dollar smash
which will see Brie Larson reprise her role
as the uber-powerful cosmic hero.
Also heavily rumored to be in active development
is Nova, a solo vehicle for the even more
powerful hero who should have an intimate
connection to the Guardians.
Essentially Marvel's answer to DC's Green
Lantern, the "man called Nova" is Richard
Rider, an Earthling imbued with the power
of the entire Nova Corps, the cosmically-powered
armed forces of the planet Xandar.
As you may recall, Xandar came under threat
by the Infinity Stone-wielding Ronan the Accuser
in the first Guardians film.
In the comics, Rider is chosen at random by
the Xandarian Rhomann Dey to house the power
of the Nova Corps after the planet's destruction.
Rider is also imbued with the "Xandarian Worldmind"
basically the collective knowledge of the
entire Xandarian race.
That's right, Nova is basically the most robust
supercomputer one can imagine... a supercomputer
that can punch a planet out of its orbit.
King Geek and Marvel mastermind Kevin Feige
has also recently teased that there is indeed
another team-up film on the way, although
he characteristically held back any relevant
details.
Since Marvel's "phases" are running a bit
shorter now Phase 4 is taking place over 2020
and 2021, with Phase 5 taking up 2022 and
2023 it seems likely that we'll be getting
an official announcement on this sometime
pretty soon, unless it gets pushed off until
Phase 6.
At any rate, we'll just have to wait until
Feige and company see their way clear to cluing
us in on when we can expect the Guardians
of the Galaxy, Blade, Captain Marvel, Ant-Man
and the Wasp, Nova, and The Avengers whatever
the heck the next iteration of that team will
look like to return to theaters.
Of course, we'll be all over any breaking
Marvel news, and we'll be sure to keep you
informed.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.